Ryland is a drunk food ramen is like the
late though it's like 20% sometimes like
you got the grandma sitting in the
kitchen just like she's constantly
churning out both of us and like people
stumbling on what are you tellin is
available always like have you ever
heard of instant foie
like that's not something that exists
very true because you can make it
quickly on Victor and but it's literally
boiling in my blessing I would wake up
every morning and smell for bringing you
back yeah it is been your back back when
I was a kid my alarm clock was my mom's
fun I would be sleeping and wake up and
smell her fought in the kitchen and
immediately wake up and just go straight
into a big hot broth of and it was like
the best thing in the world
give me morning or lunch but I just
always had it in the morning with my mom
and my brother and it's just a good
feeling that eaten when you wake up and
you just like want to wake up and
instead of coffee follows my caffeine
all right not a good thing as a kid the
most important part of the fun is like
the broth and to get that really clean
rich broth you need like a good need a
good quality cut of beef so I think like
my mom uses beef tri-tip put it in like
this giant like cauldron and cook it for
I think like six or seven hours and like
by the time it comes out is like just
rich rich fatty broth of like pure
goodness it's like white gold I think my
name is echo and I have some childhood
memories with ramen like my mom would
make it sometimes and then I would also
just like make it for myself I can't
stand Roman as a kid but I think I don't
know if that counts but I think like a
history cut it starts more like when I
moved to LA I started working in a ramen
restaurant
and it's interesting that you said faux
wakes you up in the morning because I
think Robin does the exact opposite for
me is like it does so on the same way
like when are you wrong and I'm like if
I crash because it's so so rich and
fatty it's really good but like I don't
know it's different from [ __ ] and I act
like good night absolutely like the
minute I eat it I'm just like okay well
I'm I'm done for the day
that's the end okay this is actually
like from exactly a place I used to work
careful with my people over there I
won't try which one do you use like I
use both you I just do like half and
half and I put it like on the side or
like usually what I was taught was like
toys put the sauce on the side because
when you put it in the actual broth they
change the flavor quite a bit and like
that's almost like a slap in the face to
the chef
my mom would like scold me like do the
chaucer's like smack me so I like I'm
just like a condition to put on the side
okay but again like it's whatever you
want to do you know like I feel like I
have to put it on the side yeah yeah I
don't want to I'm gonna come from behind
it's kinda like to thank you with chops
yeah yeah I'm seeing a lot of bean
sprouts oh I don't
yeah since bill what type of meat is is
it beef it looks like these it looks so
I think that's a beef brisket okay it's
like then cut a little bit of fat on it
okay so I'm gonna try to get like a
little bit of everything oh I see
cilantro oh you should try the broth for
a section oh try the broth just myself
just to like just a taste the six hours
of pure goodness that's gonna come down
your throat okay it's a lot riding on
this are you are you are you awake is
that your caffeine yeah I don't it is
very light yes oh I can see like eating
this and then doing something else right
I'm probably not gonna be like comatose
after this did yeah I don't I don't mean
when I eat it like I'd put the needles
I put the noodles on the spoon
and then like I take the meat and like
dip it in the sauce and I okay to hand
tuple one you know okay double fisting
shoot whatever you're comfortable with
yeah yeah I want to eat this the right
way just like the whole thing yeah I
mean like you had a slurp some soup in
there too you like all right use your
spoon you know of those are making you
look there was no way this was gonna be
glamorous at all
how's it how's it what's what's going in
your head what's what's your thoughts
it's pretty good there's not I feel like
maybe this is just me being biased but I
feel like there's a lot of light flavors
right going on whereas like I feel like
it's not as like like complex yeah yeah
like it's very it's a very basic food
this is like I mean hey it's good I'm
just saying like there's more depth to
the flavor in ramen didn't be the insult
my mom is like oh she doesn't breaking
chopsticks right now yeah I know so I
agree with that sentiment like fudge
it's very light and it's like known for
its kind of like not with a basic flavor
but like light airiness it is kind of
simplistic yeah yeah it's so like first
known for its light simplistic flavors
and then the thing is I have all these
herbs like the bean sprouts the basil
and then the green onions like they all
like kind of come together with the meat
and the broth and the soup noodles all
the things create like one symphony in
your mouth and then you just like feel
good afterwards all right yeah all right
shall we I usually like use the
chopsticks to like get the yolk in the
broth oh well but you okay so like I
love eggs mm-hmm and like the way that
you know Japanese folks cook their eggs
like semi hard-boiled is like
hey just me I don't know I'm not a
saying like eight porn there you go I
love it when it's like not cut yet and
then like I'm so basic but I would like
do boomerang of opening and like the egg
coming out like eight porn
I love telephone busy but I I just love
again ramen it's good but not [ __ ] it
you know initially you got the ramen
noodles you have the beautiful soft
boiled egg and then the thick cut
tonkatsu I believe which is pork some
cots ele that runs particularly because
I know hates exactly um kind of creamy I
don't think that's bad maybe some other
people would think this but I it's like
very it's pretty salty yeah try the
broth first that's pretty good
it's not basic there's a lot of texture
my mouth right now just from the broth
only and it's really creamy really
smooth at the same time and like not too
salty actually yeah that's gonna be
overly salty because you mentioned it
but pewdie I'm good
it's mommy it there's that's yet mommy
yeah I'm like jealous right now I could
it was my peoples food um right here it
goes there's so much weird ain't nice
you all know what you're doing with your
ramen for sure but I'm gonna take a nap
after this you know you can go back to
work if you need to like fix your life
so we'll get you there if I need to fix
my life I do need to fix my life so
maybe I'll just do you want to switch
yeah can I switch yes no I is it just
like work that's really good
that's exactly ramen is universal
everyone loves it it's it's just it's
just a universally loved food yes I I
think you could say that is more true
about ramen than [ __ ] but maybe that is
just me
but time out time off when people are
dying like from the hangover they're
like oh let's give ramen they're like oh
my god like a bowl of pho he's gonna fix
me up right now so like they wake up
like ramen is a drunk food ramen is like
the locals in late though is like 24/7
sometimes like you got the grandma
sitting in the kitchen just like she's
constantly churning out both of us and
they're like people are stumbling that
not all of us have a grandma who makes
fun most of us Lee what do you talk
ramen is available always like
late-night you could get like even if
like a restaurant isn't open you could
get like an instant ramen pack and
that's that's the other thing there's
instant ramen packs that we have you
could buy at 7-eleven have you ever
heard of instant Fah
like that's not something that exists I
I know you have nostalgic attachment to
I know when you have a nostalgic
attachment to food there's not much that
can change your view on it it's always
gonna be comforting and it's always
gonna taste like home that being said I
don't think there's a comparison here I
mean I understand that the sake of this
video this is a comparison but I think
this is just the food you're gonna
gravitate to I mean III there's great
flavor in that it's light it's basic but
personally I feel ramen is is the thing
you want just generally
on a day-to-day basis Robin is the thing
you're gonna want more than pho in LA
there's so much good ramen like wherever
you go you could get a good volt like
let me call my mom I'll fly out to LA
and she will make you the best full of
that would just it'll hug you as you eat
it it'll give you a shelter for your
heart and your soul
I already have a shelter for my heart
and it is in this border I will always
love which place my heart
I'm sorry yet but I think this one goes
Robin yes like steadfast fell lover this
is this is the he's even he says this is
the better the better ramen ramen just
takes it home I think I do not want to
do this at all but yes sleep with it and
your comatose ramen I will sleep with it
well I go to work and enjoy life feel
good in my heart I feel victorious is
how I feel because Robin is clearly has
clearly taken home the trophy for today
you just handed me a trophy